doctors have been feeling the effects of
the National Drug shortage with some
life-saving drugs that are hard to come
by Southern Nevada doctors are worried
in some cases it could mean life or
death eight news now reporter Victoria
Saha tells how oncologists and patients
are navigating this difficult time
cancer the c word no one ever wants to
hear it's scary because the first thing
you think of is well how much time do I
have left 43 year old Eric Tope is
battling stage four colorectal cancer I
spoke with him as he was getting
chemotherapy Tuesday so none of us like
to come in here and do these treatments
but we it saves Our Lives it's a
life-saving drug that Tope now has to be
on the waiting list for because of a
national shortage normally these
chemotherapy drugs are delivered every
two days but now there's a three to four
week wait which means delaying treatment
for patients it's scary thought that you
can't have that access to that drug
sometimes we may have a delay your
treatment never in this country would
thought we would have to ration
chemotherapy drugs while patients of Dr
rupesh Parikh are battling cancer he is
left with a different battle now
figuring out who can get the drugs that
are available we pick and choose by
level of severity we pick and choose by
the disease state but sometimes there's
not a right answer what's the response
that you get surprise shot aimed her
sometimes he says they try to order
enough of the chemo drugs but some of
the companies that make them aren't
making enough or dealing with a low
profit margin if there's nobody making
these shots then what do we do right do
we go to drugs that are more toxic
potentially that we may have to do that
as for the many patients like Tope the
future is unknown we're all trying to
fight you have to accept what the
outcomes could possibly be